-How you doing? How's the fam?
How's the kids?
How's Faith Hill?
-I mean, everybody's great,
you know?
We got a 25-year-old,
a 23-year-old,
and a 20-year-old, all girls.
-I heard this now --
you guys are empty nesters now,
you and Faith.
-The best thing about it is,
you know, Faith said
the other night -- we were --
we had the fireplace going,
we had the doors open,
we were having a glass of wine.
And it was like -- Faith said,
"You know, it's like
we're the kids
and the parents are gone."
[ Laughter ]
-It's the opposite now.
You guys are having dance
parties and stuff? That's fun.
-Oh, we're having dance parties.
We're having so much fun.
I kind of like it.
Then they come home
and they stay for like
three or four days,
and then it turns into a week.
And then you're like,
"Mm, yeah."
-"We did this, now.
Yeah, come on! We did this!"
-"It's time to go."
-"We got a new life now, yeah."
You guys -- is this true? --
you celebrated 25 years
together, you and Faith?
-Yeah, 26 coming up in October.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You got to tell her --
You have to tell her hello
for me, please.
-I will.
-How did you propose to Faith?
Do you remember that?
-Yeah, I do.
We were pla--
I want to say it was Montana.
It was somewhere in
the middle of nowhere.
We had this big festival,
and we had been touring together
for a little while.
And it -- [ Chuckles ]
Apropos for a country music
concert,
we had trailer houses --
were our dressing rooms.
-Sure.
-[ Chuckles ]
We were doing this big festival,
and we were in
this trailer house.
And I had, like,
my mirror and my --
my road case and everything
set up.
And I asked Faith, I said,
"Look."
This was right before
I went on stage.
I said, "You know, I want you
to be my wife."
She goes, "Well, you've asked me
that several times."
I go, "This time I'm serious."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, but this is --
you're in a trailer.
-Yeah, we're in a trailer.
-Yeah.
-She goes, "You're asking me
to marry you
at a country music festival
in a trailer park."
And I said, "Yes, ma'am, I am."
[ Laughter ]
"You're from Mississippi.
I'm from Louisiana.
It seems pretty appropriate."
-Yeah.
-And then when I came back
offstage,
she had written in lipstick,
"Yes, I'm gonna be your wife."
[ Audience awws ]
[ Applause ]
Yeah.
-That's fantastic.
-And I still have that mirror.
-You have the mirror?
-I still have the mirror.
-Oh, my gosh.
Tim, I've known you
for a while now.
I got to tell you -- you are
unbelievable in "1883."
-Ah, thank you.
-You hit it out
of the park, man.
This is unbelievable.
-Yes.
-I mean, wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
You crushed it, buddy.
You crushed it.
And you're also
back on the road.
-Yeah, we're touring right now.
Tomorrow night I'm in Cleveland.
-Wow.
How's it feel to be back on --
-"Hello, Cleveland."
-"Hello, Cleveland.
You made four rights, well,
that's a circle," yeah.
How is it performing in front of
live audiences again?
-It's so awesome.
It's been six years since
I've done a solo tour.
-Geez.
-Yeah, the last tour was
Faith and I doing "Soul2Soul,"
which was '17-'18.
But I'm glad to be back with
my band, my guys, you know,
and playing music
and playing new songs.
And we're in the middle of
recording a new album
at the same time.
-That's what I'm talking about.
-Yeah.
-That's part of you.
That's part of your brain.
That's the way you work.
-I like to work, you know.
-You're Tim McGraw, yeah.
And what's it like working with
Faith as your wife on "1883"?
-It was good.
-Yeah.
You definitely, I mean --
[ Laughter ]
-It was good.
-Yeah.
-And we said, "You know, it's
gonna be tough because people
are going to see Faith and Tim
on screen,
and we have to overcome that."
-Yeah.
-And so we sort of gave
each other a high-five
and gave each other a kiss
and said, "You know what?
The only way to do it is
just try to be good at it."
-Yeah, and boy --
-However...
However, there was a scene that
we did where she had to slap me.
[ Laughter ]
-But it's not a real slap.
It's a TV slap.
-No, that was a real slap.
[ Laughter ]
No.
-Was that your idea?
-Well, we talked about it
before.
You know, we don't want to do
a TV slap.
We want to do a real slap, but
after about the eighth take...
[ Laughter ]
-Faith is like, "I need one
more. I need one more.
Let's do one more.
I need one for me."
-I was concussed a bit.
And I told her afterward,
I said, "Do we need to talk?"
[ Laughter ]
"Is there something going on
I don't know about?"
-That's so funny. Oh, my God.
-'Cause, you know, I was
expecting like, a good...
You know, finger slap.
-Yeah.
-No, it was a palm.
[ Laughter ]
-She's, like, closing her fist.
You're like
"Hey, don't punch me," yeah.
-It was like Rocky hitting me.
[ Laughter ]
-Can we explain to everyone
what "1883" is about?
-Well, "1883" is sort of the
origin story of "Yellowstone,"
which I know a lot of you guys
have seen "Yellowstone."
-Yeah. Absolutely.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
Which I'm a huge fan of.
Faith and I have both been
a huge fan of since
the very first night
of the very first show.
And then, Taylor Sheridan
called,
who's one of
the most brilliant writers
in the history of Hollywood.
-Right?
-The way he writes.
And he asked if I would do
some flashback stuff
for "Yellowstone."
And then, long story short,
you know, I wanted to do it.
I said, "But I don't want to be
this country singer
that shows up at the bunkhouse
and gets taken to
the train station.
So, if we can come up with
something cool..."
And he came up with the idea of
us being the original Duttons
who founded
the Yellowstone dynasty.
-And what a layered character
you play.
-Yeah, it was so cool.
You know, and Faith and I have
never acted together.
You know, we'd never done
anything on screen together,
other than videos, and it was --
-Yeah, just toured together.
So it was so cool to be able
to work with her.
-She's great as well.
-Yeah.
She blew me away
every single day.
You know, she was so nervous.
She had done two movies before.
And I'd done a few movie--
handful of movies.
But she showed up every day
and just blew me away.
-Yeah.
-She elevated my game every day.
-You two together, man. Yeah,
you were fantastic as well.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Tim McGraw in "1883."
Take a look at this.
-You got it all figured out,
don't you?
You say you love her.
But you won't ever love her
like I do.
That's my heart
you're running off with.
You better cradle it
like an egg.
-That's what I'm talking about!
[ Cheers and applause ]
You crushed it, buddy!
You crushed it!
I'm sure I'll be seeing you
at these award shows.
Tim McGraw, everybody.
"1883" is streaming now
on Paramount+.
Go check it out, and go see him
on tour, his "McGraw Tour 2022."